[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette critique du documentaire lady
sapiens à la recherche des femmes de la
préhistoire un documentaire français qui
a été réalisé par thomas cirotteau et
qui a été diffusé sur france 5 dans le
cadre du programme sciences grand format
et ce documentaire est bien il nous
propose une vision nouvelle de la femme
de cro magnon c'est à dire de la femme
homo sapiens du paléolithique européen
donc le but c'est de donner une vue plus
moderne en fait d'eux des
représentations que l'on se fait de la
femme de cro magnon bon cro magnon c
c'est ce qu'on sait la façon dont on
désigne nous en france les homo sapiens
qui vivait au palis paléolithique en
europe donc c'est pas un terme qui est
très précis mais bon je vois là je vais
utiliser pendant cette vidéo le terme
cro magnon pour dire homo sapiens du
paléolithique d'europe donc voilà un
portrait moderne de la femme homo
sapiens j'ai reçu évidemment beaucoup de
demandes pour faire une critique de ce
documentaire de lady sapiens alors
beaucoup beaucoup de demandes qui
demandaient les critiques une critique
honnête un des gens qui ne savaient pas
quoi penser du documentaire finalement
qui se posait des vraies questions et on
va voir qu'il ya des raisons pour ça le
documentaire a des points 2 des points
qui sont vraiment pas très claires et
qui à mon avis ont pu laisser dans la
tête des gens pas mal de questions je
vais essayer de vous apporter mon
éclairage qui va être assez limité ça va
être somme toute limité parce que parce
que je suis parquet aux log je vous
rappelle que paléontologie et
archéologie sont deux disciplines
totalement différente et que parler de
la culture d'homo sapiens au
paléolithique en europe c'est
franchement de l'archéologie plus que de
la paléontologie donc à la base je
voulais pas trop parler de ce
documentaire mais bon vu que j'ai vu que
j'ai reçu plein dit mais vu que j'ai
reçu plein de demandes de clarification
et que j'ai reçus en plus ses emails qui
demandait de des bunkers voilà je dis
stop ça suffit il faut clarifier les
choses faut clarifier les choses pour
que je vous explique non je ne vais pas
démolir un truc juste parce qu'ils
existent voilà ou parce que vous le
trouvez trop féministes ou pas assez
donc ça c'était pour vous expliquer
pourquoi je me permets de vous donner
mon avis maintenant il ya une deuxième
chose que j'aimerais mettre au clair
avant qu'on commence cette vidéo n'est
pas prévu comme une attaque contre
jennifer garner donc jennifer garner de
la chaîne hbo ne laisse archéologie qui
est aussi une archéologue et qui a écrit
enfin qui a participé à l'écriture du
livre l'aï dit sa place aujourd'hui on
va pas parler du tout du livre les dix
sapiens on va uniquement parler du
documentaire documentaire auquel n'a pas
participé
elle n'a pas été intervenantes et son
nom ne figure nulle part au générique
donc jennifer garner n'a rien à voir
avec ce documentaire est donc je voulais
juste être très clair sur le fait que
cette critique n'est pas une agression
envers jennifer garner voilà donc ceci
étant maintenant dit on va s'intéresser
aux documentaires lady sapiens est
uniquement aux documentaires et il ya
une raison extrêmement pratique à cela
c'est que alors lady sapiens pour ceux
qui savent mais peut-être que vous ne le
savez pas mais lady sapiens il ya un
documentaire il y à un livre et il ya
apparemment un jeu vidéo alors déjà vous
aurez compris que le jeu vidéo je suis à
peine au courant donc je suis pas un
gamer du tout je reçois énormément aussi
de review de demandes de review de jeu
là des jeux comme far cry par exemple où
je sais que qu'il y avait eu beaucoup de
gens qui m'avaient demandé de me dire de
dire est ce que c'est un bon jeu en
termes scientifiques mais je n'en sais
rien parce que je joue pas aux jeux
vidéo donc je ne peux pas vraiment vous
aider de ce point de vue là je peux pas
faire de critiques de jeux vidéo même
ceux qui sont en lien avec la
paléontologie quoi comme arc ou ou far
cry parce que je
pense que je n'ai aucune idée de ce
qu'il ya dedans et je n'aurais jamais le
temps de 10 jouer en fait c'est surtout
ça je n'ai absolument pas le temps d'y
jouer j'aimais bien les jeux vidéo il ya
15 ans mais j'ai arrêté il ya 15 ans
quoi j'ai pu le temps j'ai juste eu le
temps donc les jeux bon bah le jeu vidéo
lady sapiens je ne peux pas en parler du
coup le livre lady sapiens je vais pas
en parler pour j'en parlerai
probablement pas dans un avenir récents
pour une simple et bonne raison une
raison très pratique bassement pratique
c'est que j'habite en afrique du sud et
que à chaque fois que je commande un
livre français il est perdu
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que je
commande des livres en france bat il
faut qu'il fasse le voyage depuis france
et puis quelque part entre la drogue
entre la douane et chez moi le livre
disparaît voilà mais ça marche aussi
avec tout ça marche pas qu'avec les
livres quasiment tout ce que je commande
ou que je ou qu'on m'envoie de france
disparaît entre la douane et chez moi
bon bah c'est le service postal sud
africain j'ai envie de dire on a appris
à faire avec mais du coup je ne
commenterai pas le livre lady sapiens va
falloir que j'attende de rentrer en
france pour pouvoir l'acheter
directement je le dire et ce ne sera pas
demain la veille puisque je vous
rappelle que nous sommes dans un état de
pandémie mondiale donc ça va pas arriver
tout de suite tout de suite donc je vais
m'intéresser purement et simplement au
documentaire donc lady sapiens
documentaire qui comme je les dis tente
de dresser un portrait moderne de la
femme homo sapiens de la femme de cro
magnon c'est à dire du paléolithique
européen alors déjà j'aime bien parce
que c'est bien défini on va parler des
représentations va pas parler vraiment
de cro magnon lui même et on va parler
des représentations qu'on fait de la
femme de cro magnon donc de la femme
homo sapiens du paléolithique européen
c'est-à-dire qu'ils s'intéressent même
pas à néandertal on sait comme je les
dis c'est une histoire qui commence
autour de 40 mille ans il ya encore des
néandertal à l'époque mais on va même
pas s'intéresser à néanderthal nom va
s'intéresser qu'à sapiens donc tu as
déjà j'aime bien ses cadres et ses
carrés on sait dans quelle borne on est
ça pour un documentaire moi je trouve
que c'est pas mal ça ça nous promet de
ne pas aller se disperser aux quatre
vents et ça je trouve ça vachement bien
donc maintenant on pourrait s'interroger
déjà sur la pertinence de donner un
portrait moderne de la femme aux seins
bien ça veut dire quoi un portrait
moderne bon pour ça je pense il va
falloir faire un distinguo entre
justement paléontologie et archéologie
la façon dont se représenter les femmes
en évolution humaine elle est très
différente en archéologie en archéologie
du paléolithique et en paléontologie
il ya une raison très simple pour ça
c'est lucy
lucy qui a été découvert dans les années
70 a été au coeur d'absolument tous les
débats
paléontologique sur l'évolution humaine
au moins pour les hominidés anciens donc
ça ça ça a mis la femme enfin le les
femelles pour le coup les femelle
australopithèque au coeur de tous les
débats au coeur de tous les débats
scientifiques mais aussi au coeur de
toutes les représentations
paléontologique de l'évolution humaine
donc en paléontologie
on a depuis très longtemps depuis au
moins les années soixante dix mille et
femmes au centre du débat par nécessité
parce qu'on a trouvée parce que le seul
squelette qu'on avait littéralement
c'était une femelle donc voila c'était
lui si quand on arrive au paléolithique
européen donc avec des homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes là on commence à
avoir un problème un problème tout bête
c'est que le dimorphisme sexuel
presque disparaît les hommes homo
sapiens donc les mâles homo sapiens
deviennent de plus en plus féminin dans
leur caractère hausse théologique donc
leur squelette ressemble de plus en plus
à celui d'une femme et il ya très très
peu de façon de distinguer un squelette
d'homo sapiens mal d'un squelette d'homo
sapiens femelle au fur et à mesure qu'on
progresse
en fait vers le paléolithique européen
et ça du coup basse a entraîné un
problème bête c'est qu'on avait du mal à
s'exciter les squelettes qu'on a trouvés
et on a eu tendance enfin je veux dire
les scientifiques du temps jadis ont eu
tendance à attribuer les squelettes des
hommes par défaut donc donc il ya une
surreprésentation de squelettes masculin
et une sous représentation des
squelettes féminin bref il ya donc un
véritable phénomène d'invisibilité ation
de la femme dans nos représentations du
paléolithique européen ça veut pas dire
que la femme était invisible à l'époque
du paléolithique ça veut dire que dans
nos représentations moderne de cette
époque paléolithique on a tendance à un
visibiliser les femmes voilà il ya un
vrai phénomène les hommes sont au centre
de la recherche voilà et du coup il
interprète les choses avec leurs yeux
d'homs et de leurs yeux d'hommes qui ont
grandi dans une société dominée par les
hommes donc c'est difficile j'ai envie
de dire d'interpréter les choses
autrement que par le prisme des
déformations qu'on a déjà devant les
yeux quoi donc lee s'est passé c'est un
phénomène qui existe on peut pas nier
l'existence de ce phénomène c'est là où
je veux en venir donc on peut pas nier
l'existence de ce phénomène et ça
devient un problème quand on tente
d'invisibles lisez encore plus les
femmes et de les soumettre en prenant en
faisant un appel à la nature et en
disant tu vois ça a toujours été comme
ça depuis le paléolithique alors
maintenant tu fermes ta gueule et tu vas
faire tu veux faire la vaisselle et
occuper des gosses voilà là ça devient
un problème ça devient un problème pour
la société on va dire donc il y a un
vrai phénomène d'invisibilité ation de
la femme dans les représentations du
paléolithique européen et c'est et ce
documentaire essaye en quelque sorte de
donner une vision un peu plus moderne on
va dire de cette représentation de la
femme agrémenté justement avec des
découvertes archéologiques et
ethnologiques récente donc ça c'est ce
que propose de faire le documentaire
maintenant la grande question c'est est
ce qu'il le fait bien et c'est là où
justement je commence la critique donc
pour cette critique je vais d'abord
commencer par les bons points bon déjà
le bon point après le bon point par
défaut j'ai envie de dire c'est que
c'est un documentaire français ça fait
toujours plaisir de voir des experts
francophones s'exprimer s'exprimer
devant les caméras parce que ça montre
qu'il y à des experts francophones et
pour ceux d'entre vous qui veulent
devenir qui veulent devenir archéologue
ou paléontologues il est bon de savoir à
qui s'adresser parce que ce sont des
gens ouverts et qui sont prêts à vous
écouter voilà donc ça c'est le premier
bon point un documentaire qui est local
deuxième bon point je pense et je pense
que c'est vraiment le super bon point et
là je bravo juste je veux dire bravo à
thomas cirotteau homo sapiens noir merci
enfin
enfin une représentation d' homo sapiens
noir parce que vous rappelez vous le prg
le documentaire premier rome ni n'avait
pas représentés homo sapiens comme étant
noir et ça m'avait énervé pourquoi pas
parce que homo sapiens on sait qu'il
était noir en sortant d'afrique il
sortait d'afrique il ya des analyses
génétiques qui ont démontré que homo
sapiens et et noir sont en afrique il ya
des analyses génétiques qui ont démontré
comme sapiens et et noir en arrivant en
europe et il ya des analyses génétiques
les mêmes analyses génétiques ont montré
comment sapiens r ce thé noir en europe
pendant un sacré bout de temps donc
c'est des choses qui sont désormais bien
soutenu dans la littérature scientifique
donc ça fait du bien de voir un
documentaire qui enfin prend les devants
et nous montre des homo sapiens noir au
paléolithique en europe parce que c'est
probablement c'était probablement le cas
voilà c'est tout c'est pas parce que je
veux de la représentativité de la
diversité non c'est parce que c'était
probablement le cas s'est même dit
d'ailleurs dans la narration un lady
sapiens avait labo noir elle avait la
peau noire pourquoi parce que ses
ancêtres étaient africains et que le
changement de couleur ça se fait pas en
deux coups de cuillère à pot ça prend du
temps c'est une adaptation à le
changement de le changement de couleur
de la peau c'est une adaptation au
moindre ensoleillement en europe ensuite
autre bon point c'est le genre de
documentaire que j'aime parce qu'il nous
montre d'où viennent les découvertes il
nous montre les scientifiques les
scientifiques sont directement
interroger et les scientifiques sont pas
là pour nous raconter des salades
parce que si vous vous rappelez la
critique que j'avais fait du jurassique
fight club mon dieu que c'est douloureux
de voir
d'écran spécialiste des dinosaures comme
philip currie et laurence wittner venir
sur un plateau télé être interrogé pour
nous dire simplement dit dans ce
dinosaure il était super gros et super
méchant [ __ ] ça sert à rien ça sert à
rien donc là au moins on a des vrais
spécialistes qui viennent pour nous
raconter des vrais trucs intéressants et
on nous montre d'où viennent les
hypothèses et ça c'est intéressant aussi
voilà quand on quand on nous parle quand
on nous parle de la forme des femmes
homos sapiens au paléolithique quand on
nous parle de la morphologie des homo
sapiens au paléolithique on nous montre
des squelettes on nous montre des vénus
donc les sculptures on débat de est ce
que ces sculptures sont des
représentations
fidèle ou pas de femmes qui ont
réellement existé bref on nous montre du
matériel et ça c'est bien les les choses
qu'on nous raconte ne sortent pas de
nulle part et ça c'est ce que j'aime
dans un documentaire les gens qui
suivent la chaîne savent que je suis
extrêmement casse pieds en matière de
documentaire je n'aime pas les
documentaires parce que la plupart des
documentaires déjà sont trop longs je
viens ils sont beaucoup trop longs pour
ce qu'ils racontent ils pourraient
facilement raconter ce qu'ils tout ce
qu'il raconte en dix minutes voire 15
minutes et ils prennent 50 minutes pour
vous raconter ça et et il nous montre
jamais le pourquoi il pense tout ce
qu'il pense et ça ça m'énerve encore un
autre bon point justement sur la
longueur du documentaire le documentaire
fait quand même une heure trente et
franchement je me suis pas fait chier
pendant 1h30 jeu c'était bien je veux
dire je ne suis pas ennuyé donc c'était
vraiment pas mal et c'est certainement
lié à cette abondance un de données
scientifiques qui nous sont présentés
tente archéologiques que éthologique
donc voilà ça c'était pour la liste des
bons points maintenant les petites
étrangeté ubisoft ça ça a été un truc
qui m'a un petit peu interpellé ubisoft
donc à participer au documentaire ils
ont le droit c'est leur droit mais du
coup ils ont inséré des images de
synthèse d'homo sapiens et ça fait super
bizarre pourquoi faire des images de
synthèse d'homo sapiens je viens homo
sapiens et nous suffit de nous maquiller
voilà suffit de maquiller des acteurs et
puis tu as une image qui est beaucoup
plus réaliste le lien donc on se
retrouve dans ce documentaire avec des
images de synthèse générés par ubisoft
donc ubisoft pour ceux qui ne savent pas
ce sont basses et les jeux vidéo c'est
une ils font des jeux vidéo je crois que
c'est eux qui ont fait far cry je crois
que c'est eux qui ont fait assassin's
creed et là vous pouvez sentir à quel
point je ne suis pas à l'aise sur le
sujet des jeux vidéo j'espère que vous
vous en rendez compte
mais voilà le hub isoft à participer à
ce documentaire en produisant des images
de synthèse de reconstruction d'homo
sapiens du paléolithique et ça fait
juste bizarre en fait dans le
documentaire parce que c'est
soudainement vous avez des images de
synthèse d'êtres humains alors je
suppose que c'est d'une part pour faire
la promo du jeu vidéo et d'autre part
peut-être pour aller draguer un petit
peu le marché des gamers c'est une
étrangeté je sais pas quoi en penser
voilà j'ai mis ça dans la catégorie et
tran jeter parce que je sais pas trop
quoi en penser d'eux disons que ça donne
un petit côté un peu brouillon en fait
aux documentaires du coup parce qu'on a
ce mélange des images réelles et images
de synthèse parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
images de synthèse en fait il ya des
représentations d'homo sapiens dans le
documentaire qui sont des gens maquillée
et il y à des images de synthèse donc
c'est ce mix en fait entre les images
réelles et les images de synthèse qui
donne cette impression un peu
brouillonne en fait c'est à dire on a on
pouvait faire des images de synthèse
alors les amis maintenant passons aux
mauvais point enfin aux points négatifs
on va dire du documentaire et je pense
que tous les points négatifs du
documentaire à peu près tous les
reproches qu'on peut faire à ce
documentaire
rentre dans la catégorie ce documentaire
est mal écrit c'est à dire que je
conteste pas la science qui a dans le
documentaire comme j'ai dit je suis pas
spécialiste du tout et même si même si
j'avais un peu de compétences en
archéologie du paléolithique je me
retiendrais de donner des avis tranchés
parce que je serais tout à fait au
courant mais je le suis déjà que les
avis divergent il ya de grosses
divergences d'opinion que donc je ne me
risquerai pas à donner un avis tranché
de toute façon je suis pas spécialiste
de l'archéologie paléolithique
européenne par contre je sais voir un
documentaire mal écrit qu'en juin et ce
documentaire il a vraiment des gros
problèmes d'écriture c'est visible en
fait à l'image qui n'a pas été écrit par
une seule personne et ça ça devient un
problème en fait si ça se voit à l'écran
que ça n'a pas été écrit par une seule
personne donc je vais vous donner des
exemples je pense que ce sera plus
parlant mais voilà des exemples
d'écriture un peu un peu maladroite il
ya un moment où on voit josé braga
fameux paléanthropologue de toulouse qui
nous parle de comment on peut c'est que
c'est laid comment on peut c'est que
c'est les squelettes donc comment on
peut déterminer si c'est un mâle ou une
femelle à partir de l'oreille interne
donc on le voit faire un site is khan
d'oreille interne donc grâce aux rayons
x il reconstruit en 3d l'oreille interne
très belles images ça prend une longue
section du documentaire et on nous
explique que ça marche très bien à 95%
on peut arriver à c'est que c'est un
fossile de
d'hominidés rien qu'en regardant son
oreille interne ce avec quoi je suis
tout à fait d'accord je veux dire je
n'ai aucun problème avec ça il ya des
publications à l'appui le problème c'est
que ça revient jamais
c'est à dire que il nous explique
comment c'est que c'est un fossile à
partir de l'oreille interne et à aucun
moment plus tard dans le documentaire on
ne voit qui que ce soit c'est que c'est
un fossile en utilisant cette technique
c'est le setup pay off donc là on vous
7up une capacité assez les fossiles en
regardant l'oreille interne et en fait
il ya jamais de pay off c'est à dire
qu'il n'a jamais aucun moment où ce sera
utilisé plus tard dans le documentaire
et ça c'est pas un énorme problème en
soi mais du coup ça donne aux
documentaires comme je le disais un
petit côté un peu brouillon c'est à dire
que du coup ça revient jamais c'est à
dire j'ai un peu l'impression de lire
une copie d'étudiants en fait quand je
l'aï quand je vois ça c'est à dire que
l'étudiant il nous raconte à quel point
c'est super génial qu'on puisse c'est
que celle et les oreilles afin qu'on
puisse c'est que c'est les fossiles
grâce aux oreilles interne et puis et
puis c'est tout une tournure encore plus
maladroite autour d'eux une heure de
documentaires on entend la phrase lady
sapiens était une femme indépendante
assisté par les autres membres de la
tribu
c'est la phrase telle qu'elle est dans
le documentaire donc elle était
indépendante mais assister on a
l'impression en fait que le script du
documentaire a pas été relu et puis
après il ya le problème majeur de
l'écriture absolument schizophrène de ce
documentaire ce documentaire comme je le
disais donne pas la pression d'avoir été
écrit par une seule personne vous avez
vraiment de niveaux de narration en fait
dans le documentaire il ya un niveau de
narration où on nous montre les données
archéologiques et ethnologiques
c'est-à-dire il ya la personne en gros
qui est allé interviewer les
scientifiques qui a mis les interviews
des scientifiques
les unes accrochés aux autres pour
raconter une histoire et puis il ya la
personne qui a écrit la voie de la
narration voilà la petite voix comme
dans comme dans c'est pas sorcier il ya
une petite voix de la narration qui vous
racontent le documentaire mais cette
voie de la narration très souvent pour
ne pas j'ai pas envie de dire
systématiquement parce que c'est pas
vrai c'est pas tout le temps mais très
souvent elle va vous raconter l'exact
opposé de ce qui est montré à l'écran
enfin je veux dire c'est cette
contradiction pendant la narration du
documentaire mais vous
comment voulez-vous comprendre le
documentaire comment voulez vous que le
documentaire soit pas polémique du coup
enfin du coup je comprends mieux enfin
quand j'ai vu le documentaire et que
j'ai vu cette écriture schizophrène j'ai
beaucoup mieux compris bah oui je
comprends pourquoi les gens ils veulent
une clarification parce qu'effectivement
ce documentaire il est écrit il est
bizarre il est bizarre il est très
bizarre pour vous donner l'exemple qui
m'a vraiment qui m'a scotché à mon siège
en mode waouh parce que le vient
vraiment de voir ce que je viens de voir
parce que je viens vraiment d'entendre
ce que je viens d'entendre c'est que on
a un archéologue qui nous balance textos
dans le documentaire on a beaucoup de
déformation osseuse due au lancer de
javelot sur les articulations du coude
et de l'épaule
donc on est capable de voir qu'il y à
des déformations osseuses dû à la chasse
est justement ce qu'il dit c'est que
presque toutes ces des formations se
retrouvaient sur des fossiles attribué à
des hommes donc en gros il nous dit la
femme homo sapiens du paléolithique elle
chasse est pas ce qu il vient de nous
dire c'est ça apparemment les données
archéologiques qu'on a à notre
disposition aujourd'hui ne permettent
pas de dire que la chasse était une
activité
fréquente chez la femme de cro magnon
c'est ce qu'il vient de nous dire et à
la fin du documentaire vous avez la voie
de la narration qui nous dit que la
femme la lady sapiens était une
chasseresse banon c'est exactement le
contraire de ce qui est dit dans le
documentaire est encore une fois moi je
remet rien en question là pour le coup
je n'ai pas mon mot à dire encore une
fois je n'ai pas mon mot à dire sur la
qualité de ces données c'est juste ce
que le documentaire me donne et est ce
que je peux en comprendre est ce que le
documentaire me donne c'est d'un côté un
archéologue qui dit la femme lady
sapiens ne chassait pas les données
archéologiques disent que lesdits
sapiens n'était pas une chasseresse et
la voie de la narration qui me dit
exactement l'opposé est maintenant en
tant que spectateur qu'est ce que je
fais de ça
comment voulez vous que le spectateur
soit pas confus comment voulez vous que
vous ayez pas des spectateurs qui d'un
côté dix c'est beaucoup trop féministe
et que de l'autre côté il ya des
spectateurs qui vous disent c'est pas
assez féministe en fait je ne sais pas
je sais pas s'ils ont essayé de
contenter tout le monde et au final du
coup ça qu'on tente personne mais yahia
voile bon bah c'est un problème
d'écriture quoi c'est un énorme problème
d'écriture un autre problème d'écriture
liées à la chasse encore une fois c'est
que donc on nous explique que dans le
paléolithique européen on a des
squelettes
des squelettes d'hommes et que c'est ce
que les hommes ont des déformations qui
indique au coude et à l'épaule qui
indique qu'ils étaient des chasseurs et
qu'on ne retrouve pas ça aussi souvent
chez les femmes que chez les hommes ce
qui indique comme je le disais que la
chasse n'était pas une activité préférée
des femmes mais plutôt des hommes ce qui
veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas des contre
exemples encore une fois je n'en sais
rien mais par contre d'un seul coup on
se téléporte en amérique du sud pour
aller chercher un exemple de femme
chasseresse en amérique du sud dans le
registre archéologiques d'amérique du
sud et ça c'est pareil ça ça c'est qu'en
face à une séquence qui aurait dû être
coupé je pense
d'un documentaire qui s'intéresse
exclusivement à la femme cro magnon
pourquoi aller jusqu'en amérique du sud
enfin là il devait dire on en parle pas
du tout de la même culture on parle pas
du tout de la même alors si on peut
parler de civilisation au paléolithique
mais on parle pas du tout de la même
civilisation
on parle pas du tout de la même culture
je pense que culture c'est vraiment le
truc quoi être des cultures qui ont
divergé il ya au moins cent mille en
quoi à la sortie d'afrique voilà ceux
qui sont partis à l'ouest ceux qui sont
partis vers l'est on parle de culture
qui ont divergé il ya super longtemps
c'est quand même chaud de faire le
parallèle entre les deux un énorme
problème avec ce genre d'interprétation
donc l'interprétation que vous voyez là
bas il y avait des chasseurs cueilleurs
en amérique du sud et ses chasseurs
cueilleurs les femmes étaient chasseuse
donc les chasseurs cueilleurs en europe
et pas forcément les femmes étaient
chasseuse enfin ce tracé cette ligne là
ça implique du coup que chasseurs
cueilleurs
c'est une culture chasseurs cueilleurs
c'est la culture primitif voilà
agriculteurs c'est la culture dérivés
donc c'est les gens évoluent et qu'ils
sont agriculteurs et qui construisent
des murs en briques les autres c'est des
chasseurs cueilleurs et ils sont
primitifs et donc ils ont tous la même
culture primitive à ça ça pique ça ça
pique même dans mes petites oreilles de
paléontologues ça pique ce genre de
tracé se base sur la notion probablement
fausse et très certainement fausse en
réalité que chasseur cueilleur c'est un
état primitif donc déjà c'est leur sujet
dans le cadre du documentaire et en plus
c'est extrêmement des maths à bhl donc
faut-il vraiment le montrer dans un
documentaire sans le nuancer parce qu'il
ya aussi ça le problème c'est qu'il faut
nuancer ce genre de choses est là
faut-il de montrer dans un documentaire
sans le nuancer
mais
voilà et puis le documentaire se termine
sur une description de lady sapiens la
fameuse voie de la narration fait une
conclusion sur les dix sapiens se dresse
un portrait de lady sapiens alors qu'il
est très conclusif je veux dire c'est
niveau-là niveau écriture pour le coup
c'est écrit parfaitement c'est c'est la
bonne intonation de voix c'est parfait
ça veut dire ça plante le clou de ce que
le documentaire a essayé de produire
mais bon comme je les dis ça contredit
beaucoup des choses que ce qui a été dit
de ce qui a été dit avant si on en croit
le portrait dressé par le documentaire
encore une fois je ne sort pas du cadre
du documentaire mais le portrait dressé
par le documentaire de lady sapiens
c'est une femme au foyer veux dire elle
s'occupe des enfants
elle et elle cueille pendant que les
hommes vont à la chasse alors ils disent
à un moment qu'il est possible qu'elle
ait aussi participé aux battues etc on
nous montre qu'elle faisait de la
couture et du très sage bon bah elle
fabriquait les outils pendant que les
âmes était à la chasse elle peignait les
grottes avec les hommes quand il
revenait de la chasse donc c'est ça
qu'on nous montre dans le documentaire
les dix sapiens nous est représentée
pendant ce temps là comme une femme au
foyer quasiment et la voie de la
narration nous dit le contraire donc
voilà le côté schizophrène du
documentaire je comprends que les gens
du coup et pas vraiment compris et que
plein de gens aient interprété ce
documentaire de plein de façons
différentes et du coup je comprends la
polémique autour du documentaire quoi
d'après ce que j'ai compris enfin je
veux dire si je reçois des messages de
gens qui me demandent de démolir
documentaire c'est que non seulement il
ya polémique mais en plus la polémique
et pas seulement académique quoi c'est
pas seulement les spécialistes qui se
foutent sur la gueule lasser c'est tout
le monde si on me demande de démolir le
documentaire est ce que beaucoup de gens
ont pas l'air d'avoir vu dans ce
documentaire à mon avis c'est justement
cette équipe cette écriture schizophrène
c'est à dire que bas il ya deux messages
dans ce documentaire qui sont parfois
voire souvent opposés l'exemple de la
chasse étant l'exemple le plus criant
je parle beaucoup de la chasse mais
c'est pas parce que la chasse me tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est juste
parce que l'exemple de la chasse est
particulièrement criant on a vraiment à
un moment un archéologue qui nous dit
femme de cro magnon pas chasseuse et un
autre moment du documentaire la voie de
la narration qui nous dit femme de cro
magnon chasseuse en conclusion que
penser de ce documentaire alors moi mon
avis personnel mon opinion de pas
spécialistes sur la question
je le recommanderais pas ce documentaire
alors je recommanderais pas de regarder
ce documentaire si vous essayez de
savoir quelle était la place de la femme
dans la société du paléolithique donc si
vous essayez de savoir quelle est la
représentation moderne de la femme du
paléolithique base documentaire il va
vous donner deux images totalement
opposé alors c'est bien du coup de
pouvoir contrastés les deux mais c'est
pas ce que fait le documentaire le
documentaire ne contraste pas les deux
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il vous
donne les deux en même temps comme si
c'était la même chose
voilà c'est peut-être aussi ça qu'il
faut mettre au clair c'est que il ne
fait pas que vous donnez deux
interprétations différentes de lady sa
place c'est qu'il voulait donne tous les
deux en même temps sans vous dire que ce
sont deux choses différentes que ce sont
deux visions différentes
je ne peux pas recommandée ça parce que
du coup vous allez pas savoir quoi
penser et c'est normal donc si le
documentaire avait contrasté ces deux
images volontairement en disant bas on a
des données qui dit ça mais on a des
données qui disent ça donc du coup on a
une image qui bon voilà
avec un groupe à la fin voilà bon ou
alors avec voilà nous notre coeur penche
pour une lady sapiens plutôt chanceuse
parce que ça ça ça et ça à la limite
j'aurais pu leur recommander ce
documentaire mais sachant que si vous
voulez savoir ce qu'étaient les dix
sapiens si vous voulez un portrait robot
de ce qui était la femme de cro magnon
bah c'est pas c'est pas un documentaire
je pense que le documentaire en fait
échouer là pour le coup je pense qu'ils
échouent dû à cet énorme problème
d'écriture je pense et ça c'est dommage
c'est dommage alors comme j'ai dit j'ai
pas lu le livre mais je pense que le
livre vu que le livre a été je crois
écrit après le documentaire j'imagine
que le livre doit corriger ce problème
je suppose du coup ça fait un peu
occasions manquées si vous voulez c'est
il avait une bonne occasion de donner
une mise à jour de l'image de lady
sapiens et à cause de ses problèmes
d'écriture elle ne ressort pas en fait
cette image ne ressort pas ce qui donne
comme je le disais à ce documentaire
cette image un peu brouillon après je le
recommanderais pour une autre raison qui
est que justement c'est un exemple
parfait absolument parfait de
documentaires de pourquoi en fait il
faut montrer les choses dans les
documentaires ça pour ça je le
recommande par contre c'est un exemple
parfait de pourquoi il faut montrer les
choses dans le documentaire d'où
viennent les preuves quelles sont les
preuves
et de fait le documentaire vous donne
les clés pour avoir un avis critique à
propos du documentaire et ça c'est
vachement bien ce que vous ne pouvez pas
faire avec un docu fiction avec un
docu-fiction vous êtes obligés
d'accepter ce qui est devant vous comme
étant la vérité parce qu'on ne vous
donne pas les clefs pour le comprendre
dans un documentaire comme lady sapiens
on vous donne les clés pour avoir un
avis critique sur le documentaire et ça
c'est vachement bien donc pour ça par
contre je le recommande encore que sa
demande d'avoir comme j'ai dit un
certain recul déjà sur le documentaire
donc voilà c'est tout ce que je pense de
lady sapiens donc comme vous voyez un
avis mitigé c'est un documentaire qui a
des qualités et qui a des défauts est ce
qu'il méritait toute cette haine je ne
pense pas je vous dis à très bientôt sur
notre chaîne salut
[Musique]